[Musique]
ce samedi 16 et dimanche 17 septembre le
département à participer à la 34e
édition des journées européennes du
patrimoine placées cette année sous le
thème jeunesse et patrimoine la
bibliothèque départementale de la
réunion à proposer au public une
nouvelle exposition intitulée il est et
112 fois une exposition à l'origine d'un
concours de création littéraire afin de
sélectionner l'album qui sera offert
pour l'opération premières pages
initiée par le ministère de la culture
l'exposition présente les 112
proposition d'albums qui ont été
réalisées d'une belle sortie familiale
sa ferme et de faire connaître à la
réunion que nous avons des talents sur
notre territoire et en même temps dans
ces journées européennes du patrimoine
montrer au tout public qu'il ya de la
créativité à la réunion
voilà sur une première appel à projets
on a cent douze créateurs qui présentent
leurs projets c'est extraordinaire et
donc nous devons continuer au niveau du
département à accompagner et à
encourager les créateurs à la réunion le
premier prix a été remporté par deux
soeurs grâce à leur album intitulé non
non et non
l'histoire d'un petit poussin amoureux
de la réunion j'avais déjà un personnage
en tête
j'avais même déjà écrit quelques lignes
des enfants d'un autre âge
j'ai repris mon personnage est adapté
j'ai adapté aux plus petits un univers
plus encore
avec ma soeur et jauger si dans ce cas
les loyers à travers à travers son texte
vivo qu'effectivement d'après
les anneaux nationale de sorte que
musique plancher sur tout
et ce petit poussin noir mais les
équipements culturels du département
ouvert leurs portes gratuitement public
pour une manifestation riche en
nouveautés
[Musique]